another one goes down as a result of the
Trump Russia investigation and this time
it is hitting very very much closer to
Donald Trump himself because Donald
Trump's personal lawyer Michael Cohen
has agreed to plead guilty to eight
different counts and these are charges
that he was facing in the Southern
District of New York he has reached a
plea agreement with prosecutors
it will include guilty pleas for
multiple crimes eight counts total and
he has surrendered to the FBI in New
York City he is in custody the charges
against them could carry prison time
potentially three to five years although
you really just don't know Paul Manafort
also convicted and will talk about his
possible prison time a little bit later
on in the program here is Michael Cohen
leaving the courthouse yesterday on what
has been I would argue the worst day so
far for the presidency of Donald Trump
August 21st 2018 16 total guilty charges
against insiders to the Trump campaign
Michael Cohen leaving the courthouse to
chance of lock him up
these are charges for tax fraud campaign
finance violations and those campaign
finance violations appear to be
specifically related to payments made to
mistresses of the candidate in order for
them not to talk now he doesn't name
Donald Trump but everything we know
about Michael Cohen so far is that his
only candidate client has been Donald
Trump supposedly he only had three
clients period for who knows how long
one of whom was sean hannity third one i
don't remember exactly who that was but
we are talking here about criminality
pleading guilty to criminality connected
to payments made to silenced mistresses
of Donald Trump
most likely stormy Daniels and Karen
McDougal so these charges are not only
serious but these are charges related to
actions during and related to the Donald
Trump campaign this is not stuff people
did years ago although at this point it
actually has actually been a couple
years it's no longer people who have
nothing to do with Trump this is one of
trumps closest confidants he was for
years and these are actions that he took
while and for he was working while he
was working for the Trump campaign I
guess is the group the least
grammatically ambiguous way of saying it
what we don't yet know is whether Cohen
is fully cooperating here sometimes plea
deals are part of a deal to fully
cooperate and to truly turn on whoever
it is you've got dirt on we don't know
we know that he seemed to be saying he
was going to do what was best for his
family
these trials can be very expensive
according to Politico a source close to
Cohen says he agreed to this not
necessarily because he's fully turning
on Trump but because he's trying to save
millions of dollars that it would likely
cost to fight this all the way to the
end and also to limit his exposure one
question is whether the campaign finance
charges related to what we now know are
are Trump's mistresses how involved was
Trump directly with those payments Trump
denied any involvement Cohen is now
saying he was directed by quote the
candidate
on that we'll talk about that a little
bit later the attorney for stormy
Daniels Michael avenatti says this is
very good for them he went to Twitter
immediately and said quote the
developments of today will permit us to
have the stay lifted in the civil case
remember he has a civil case here going
as well and should also permit us to
proceed with an expedited deposition of
Trump under oath about what he knew when
he knew it and what he did about it we
will disclose it all to the public
Michael Cohen also has some interesting
tweets in his past that relate to the
developments of the last 24 hours you
might remember that Michael Cohen
tweeted back in December of 2015
Hillary Clinton when you go to prison
for defrauding America and perjury your
room and board will be free that tweet
not aging well for Michael Cohen so what
is next number one I anticipate Rudy
Giuliani appearing on Fox News or
telling George Stephanopoulos that guilt
is now a relative term okay yeah guilty
but what is guilty even really mean
crime is a total socio-cultural
construction even defining what a crime
is is a completely arbitrary maybe even
the fact that Cohen pleads guilty
exonerates Trump in the mind of Rudy
Giuliani the truth isn't the truth
guilty isn't guilty crimes aren't crimes
nothing isin 84 nothing is anything at
this point so let's summarize Donald
Trump's first National Security Advisor
Michael Flynn pleaded guilty Donald
Trump's personal attorney Michael Cohen
pleaded guilty Trump's campaign chairman
Paul Manafort likely heading to prison
found guilty on eight of 18 counts
yesterday we'll talk about that later
Trump's foreign policy adviser George
papadopolis pleaded guilty and the list
is going to keep getting longer we have
a poll up at youtube.com slash the david
pakman show slash community asking you
who do you think is going to be the next
to be indicted in the Trump fiasco and
we will get those results to you by the
end of the week in order to contribute
draining the swamp Donald Trump will
likely react to news of Cohen pleading
guilty by stripping the security
clearance of some former intelligence
chief because there really the risk
this country right and of course if
there's nothing to see here
why do Trump associates keep pleading
pleading guilty and I'm convinced that
if Cohen does truly cooperate if Cohen
really says I'm gonna give them
everything I have it's gonna be bad for
the Trump family and I know that as a
sitting president Trump can't be
indicted but a lot of people in his
family Canon Donald Trump jr. one of the
folks at the top of that list of lot of
exposure
I feel like this um maybe this story
would be a little bit off-putting
because Cohen's guilty plea isn't
directly related to the Russia stuff
right it has to do with campaign finance
violations and it's connected to affairs
and that sort of thing like hush
payments and so some people may not like
it maybe they all would think it's like
a witch hunt
but hey the guy broke the law you can't
start the law some people might consider
it to be a witch hunt yeah I don't know
who you're thinking about there and now
I save this part for the end because
this is just huge this is maybe the
biggest part of the story as it relates
to Trump Michael Cohen is saying that
the campaign finance violations related
to the payments he made to those
mistresses were payments specifically
requested by the candidate who we all
know is Donald Trump and that's what I
want to discuss next with you